after months of fighting hundreds of
people in northeastern mozambique have
begun returning home
fighters had captured the port city of
museum boa de praya more than two years
ago
dozens of people were killed and tens of
thousands displaced during that attack
it's one of several areas recovered by
mozambican and london government forces
as part of a regional standby force
we came here with the mozambican police
for a confidence building patrol we want
to show our presence the population is
coming back but they are still very
scared and they are not feeling safe we
are telling them that the war is over
but some of those returning say they
don't feel safe under the protection of
the mozambican police
they are not protecting us they are
killing us if they were protecting us
then we would be living in peace but
that is not the case we are tired of
fleeing and we are tired of our children
being killed
in march fighters linked to isil
attacked the northern town of palma
forcing people to flee the attack has
left a trail of destruction and the
muslim beacon army struggled to push
them back in the last four years the
fighters have extended their influence
in the area
the conflict has killed more than three
thousand people and displaced at least
eight hundred thousand
and according to the united nations
nearly one million people now need
urgent food aid family al jazeera